hey leute ich bin ja ein riesen fan von
neuen technologien die noch nicht
wirklich in unserem alltag sind aber
bald unser leben verändern werden
ob selbstfahrende autos virtual reality
oder das internet der dinge
ich finds immer super spannend und habe
höchstwahrscheinlich auch schon ein
video dazu gemacht aber trage ich mit
solchen videos auch dazu bei dass leute
am ende nur von diesen erfindungen
enttäuscht werden
es gibt ein paar stationen durch die
anscheinend fast jede neue technologie
durch muss bis sie wirklich im alltag
von uns menschen angekommen ist das ist
der hype zyklus 1995 von jackie fenn
erfunden und bis heute in der
technikbranche ständig benutzt und
zitiert hier auf der y-achse befindet
sich die aufmerksamkeit oder die
erwartungen an eine neue technologie je
höher die kurve desto größer der hype
und auf der x-achse ist die zeit
eingetragen das sind meistens mehrere
jahre hängt aber total von der
technologie an
am anfang von diesem zyklus gibt es
immer einen auslöser ein
wissenschaftlicher durchbruch eine idee
oder neue forschungsergebnisse dieser
auslöser stößt auf großes interesse und
explosionsartig steigt der hype an jeder
aus dem häuschen diese neue technik wird
unser leben verändern
die medien berichten viel und ausgiebig
und die erwartungen an das neue produkt
steigen ins unermessliche
jeder will es haben was sich aber kaum
vermeiden lässt ist was jetzt kommt ein
genauso schnelle abschwung in die
enttäuschung
die ersten prototypen der neuen technik
kommt viel zu spät an und sind noch
lange nicht marktreif
sie haben kinderkrankheiten sind
überteuert und halten generell nicht das
was man sich von der neuen technik
vorgestellt hatte als folge dessen will
die presse nicht mehr darüber berichten
und die neue technologie die eigentlich
alles verändern sollte gerät erst einmal
in vergessenheit bis sie schließlich
durch weitere forschung und entwicklung
lange zeit später auf einen angemessenen
standort neue einschätzungen der technik
durch die medien sind jetzt viel
realistischer die leute verstehen die
vor und nachteile der technik und wissen
was sie kann und vor allem was sie nicht
kann und so ganz langsam kommt man dann
gegen ende der entwicklung mit der
zweiten oder dritten generation des
produkts auf eine stabile ebene das
produkt verändert am ende vielleicht
doch unser leben drastisch aber nicht
ganz so wie wir uns das zunächst
vorgestellt haben
oder stellt sich heraus dass es doch
eher ein nischenprodukt ist und wir im
alltag kaum etwas damit zu tun haben
das ist der hype zyklus kurz
zusammengefasst natürlich ist das alles
nicht wissenschaftlich es gibt zum
beispiel keine möglichkeit hype wirklich
zu messen
deswegen gibt es immer wieder
technologien die aus dem muster
herausfallen und die namen für die
einzelnen stationen sind auch irgendwie
theatralisch trotzdem gibt die firma
gartner jedes jahr einen neuen hype
zyklus chart heraus der heilige gral in
der technikbranche hier lässt sich alles
schnell ablesen welche technologien sind
gerade total im trend und super spannend
zum beispiel selbstfahrender autos
welche arbeiten sich gerade durch die
steinige entwicklung und kommen erst in
ein paar jahren wieder zum beispiel 3d
drucker für konsumenten und am
wichtigsten was steht uns in wenigen
jahren bevor
welche erfindungen kennt heute noch
keiner die bald der große hype sein
werden
akustik sense in unserer haut als
touchscreen oder smart dust schwärme von
mikro robotern und sensoren die durch
computernetzwerke kontrolliert werden
das klingt nach vielen vielen videos die
ich zu diesen ganzen themen machen kann
wobei ich dann wohl auch automatisch zum
hype und damit unausweichlich zu der
enttäuschung beitragen werde die danach
kommt es irgend ein bisschen schade dass
man nicht von anfang an realistisch an
neue erfindungen heran geben kann dass
sie anscheinend immer wieder zunächst
überbewertet werden aber ich finde den
hype cycle auch super um technologien
die schon lange verfolge besser
einschätzen zu können zum beispiel
virtual reality dieses jahr sind endlich
die ersten consumer varianten der waz
rausgekommen
und obwohl sie noch teuer umständlich
und definitiv nicht perfekt sind meine
technik so langsam an
was wirklich dahintersteckt autonome
autos befinden sich laut gartner gerade
an der spitze des heims und das glaube
ich gerne meine eigenen erwartungen an
diese technik sind gerade in der
revolution der logistikbranche
drastischer rückfall von
verkehrsunfällen und entspanntes
autofahren bei dem man filme gucken kann
noch gibt es aber nur prototypen und
dass das alles nicht so schnell geht und
nicht genau so wie wir uns das
vorstellen könnte uns bald stark
enttäuschend bis die technik dann nach
einiger forschung und harter arbeit
vollkommen im alltag angekommen ist und
von uns angenommen wurde wird wohl noch
viel zeit ins land gehen
genauso wie das internet der dinge oder
whirlpools wir haben gesehen dass das
ganze funktioniert aber momentan wollen
die wenigsten leute eintretenden toaster
oder videobrillen beim spazierengehen
wir müssen herausfinden wie man diese
dinge wirklich sinnvoll in unseren
alltag integrieren kann
wenn ihr euch für sowas interessiert
würde ich euch empfehlen einfach mal mit
dem citrix der letzten jahre um zu
spielen und zu sehen wie sich die
verschiedenen erfindungen entwickelt
haben alle links zum thema findet ihr
wie immer unten in der video
beschreibung direkt unterm like button
viel spaß dabei ich bin raus butt rein
neuer fertig